everybody Doug Walker here just me again
this time sorry doing the review I am
gonna talk about Pixar and Disney's Coco
and the short preview for frozen - which
is anything but sure it's actually like
I don't even know like 25 30 minutes
like it was really long and yeah that
was I'm gonna tell my wife going in I
said okay look this whole short frozen
thing it's riding the wave but it's also
gonna be just an excuse to sell
merchandise and I guarantee - I said
everyone's gonna be a New Clothes
particularly and at Elsa they're gonna
be an entirely new dresses that are
gonna be like designed by some sort of
high-end you know a dress designer or
something like that as sure as soon
enough as if this start she's like wow
you call it's a very cute short but yeah
Lily we walked into Walgreens afterwards
and saw merchandise for that short
already out there's at you more
merchandise for that short than there
was for Coco butts a very
christmas-related short - so blah blah
blah that was fine
and then the movie Coco started and this
is getting all sorts of great reviews
and just everyone's praising the hell
out of it and yeah I loved it - I really
really liked it my first big concern
like a lot of people is it was gonna be
too much like book of life which I did
enjoy I didn't love but but I really
enjoyed I enjoy the story and I loved
the way it looked and it really wasn't
when I saw the trailer I got that
concern because you know that the world
of the Dead does look very similar
that's really where it stops I did not
get any other connections you know
outside of its a Day of the Dead movie
but that's like saying look that movie
has the Grim Reaper that movie has the
Grim Reaper it's it's kind of a popular
idea guys it's not like you know the
Grim Reaper's gonna be a hooded guy with
a sick call usually a skull face I mean
it's just it's just kind of a common
folklore idea so what I really love
about this movie is it has so much that
I hate in these kind of cliches they
have the main character going against
the
Li's wishes they want one thing one way
and that person wants to go against the
other its hating music and this one
character loves music and wants to show
them the music can be great it has a
surprise villain again at the end that
suddenly they spring on you it has all
these little elements that just drive me
nuts but they work and the reason they
work is because they very naturally work
it into the story it's hard to see this
story without these elements it's kind
of like when I first saw Hot Fuzz for
those of you have seen this movie
there's a surprise in the last third of
Hot Fuzz where I went oh no we're doing
this oh and this movie was going so well
but then you find out it was all part of
what it was building up to it was
building up to this this great payoff at
the end but this isn't quite that it
kind of is it's a big emotional payoff
at the end it's not really a comedic
payoff and it really really works and
visually it's stunning and it's got some
wonderful songs in it it's not done
really as a musical it's done more like
somebody goes up and says I'm gonna sing
you this song gets the guitar see it's
like that it's not really like you know
I'm feeling sad I'm gonna sing about how
I feel sad you know it's not like that
but the songs are really good one of
them the main one that's gonna win the
Oscar for best song uh I don't know I'm
what did anyone else get drink with me
from lame is I got a little bit of that
it's no really good song but I'm like
drink with me I don't know I I got a
little bit of that but blah blah it's
still really good song maybe I just
heard it differently or something like
that but it's still really really nice
and what's so clever about the song is
the when you first hear it it's big and
glamorized and here's all these
showgirls you know dancing around
there's the guy with the guitar and the
big lights and then you see as the as it
goes on was originally meant for and and
the tune changes usually in these movies
it starts off small and then the song
gets bigger and bigger
I'm bigger you know at the end and it's
quite the opposite and it's very very
smart it's very clever in the way it
does that the colors leap off the screen
I mean it's just so gorgeous to look at
it's a clever idea the jokes are very
very funny it's not quite as joke heavy
as some of the air films I say like
finding dory or the toy stories or
anything like that but when they do have
jokes they work and they're really solid
I try to think like the only cuz every
time I was mentally making a note saying
oh well we're doing this cliche I'm not
gonna like that but again they so I'm
always making notes like that but then
like well we know that that worked and
oh well that they tied that into this
well this sort of came around so it's
like a lot of the problems I was having
really fix themselves in fact if
anything they weren't problems at all
it's the fact there's so many other
films that have used these cliches and
they didn't use it right this film uses
them right so the the problems I have
are very I get very nitpicky
uh there's a bit in the middle where
there's like a talent contest and he
goes up to perform and it just seemed
like an excuse to throw in another song
and it's not even like I don't know but
for me it wasn't as good as like the
other songs in the movie so and when the
scene wraps up and then you see they're
trying to get to where they're trying to
get to I was like you you could have cut
that I didn't see why that was in there
um I think that you know this might be
the only time ever where I've actually
said you know you can't killed off the
parents because they have little to no
role in this and I'm thinking to myself
yet this is out of all the Disney films
where it would have been okay if the
parents were out of the picture this is
the one so but I'm sure like they'd done
a cliche to death and they're just no
let's it's in every Disney movie let's
not do it it's kind of like the cliche
of you know wish upon a star and your
dreams will come true this one again
like a lot of current Disney films that
I want say start with princess in the
frog but maybe it started beforehand you
know now they're really trying to hammer
in no go get your dreams and you know
it's fine to wish but work for it and
stuff which I I don't know it's
debatable I always sort of thought they
taught that anyway you know and sort of
the other Disney film but I see the
argument against that too you know that
like innocent Arella on Pinocchio and
stuff like that but you know apples and
oranges you know just different points
of view uh and yeah I'm try think of
like any other problems with they had
light like not that many I don't know
why the I thought the movie Moana
because I saw the movie I thought it was
okay and I thought was decent people
just fell in love with it and I was
watching this one and I was saying you
know again these are kind of the same
these are similar cliches that were in
Moana as well but but something about
the way they were integrated into this
just felt more genuine it felt like you
was telling a more original story it
maybe it even has to do with the fact
that it's a little boy it's not you know
like it a princess of a kingdom or is
something like that you know it maybe
even just that little difference can
make a big it can be huge but I don't
know but there's other cliches that like
they did in there that I'm just like
these are fine I just seen them to death
that didn't seem like enough new stuff
was added to it here I mean it's like
just the new stuff added to it in Moana
you got these beautiful Hawaiian Lance
gage you know and in the ocean and the
islands and that's cool and I know
people love that stuff but here this is
just a whole kingdom that like you've
never seen or maybe you've seen a little
bit in book but you know what I mean
like you've seen variations of this you
know in Day of the Dead celebrations and
stuff like that but they create a world
and you find out how the world works and
you find out animals can see the dead in
this world and and I already thought
that was brilliant but then they have a
tie-in that like the animals can also
become spirit animals I can kind of
guide you and you're not even aware of
it and they have to kind of figure it
out and they could go surf in and out of
the world the den the world of living
and that's why they always see stuff
that you don't see and it's like that's
brilliant that's so brilliant
it's full of little touches like that
but I just love and you know even start
the modern-day jokes that they make you
know like that there they go to a party
at one point they're doing like dubstep
and stuff like that it's uh it doesn't
seem out of place because it is still a
current story you know but the majority
of it has a timeless feel but it's still
had but it still meant to be now so I
felt it didn't feel out of place cuz
it's sort of like a celebration of a
bunch of different time periods and
ideas and stuffs are coming together in
this world of the Dead and and it has
the very soft you know loving moments it
has the quiet moments as well one of my
favorite moments outside of the end
moment that's gotta be the cry moment
everyone was crying at the end but I
really love this scene where one of the
characters go is in the world of the
dead here you know if they could die a
second death and the first time you see
that it's done again this could have
been so cliched he sings a song to this
guy who's dying the second death he's
fading away kind of thing and how do you
usually do this you do this by singing
the really nice really sympathetic song
it's so soothing and it-it's about going
into the next world or something
romantic like that and it's not it's a
funny little song that's legitimately
funny sounds like a real song it sounds
like a funny little song you just sort
of sing to yourself very quietly and
there's even a low joke thrown in where
he has to hide what one of the words
means in front of in front of the main
character and that was so much more
effective than if they put the
traditional cliched song in there and
that's what I felt like I felt like even
with these cliches going on they put
just enough differences in there and
just enough of a different personality
to it that it felt lively it felt new
and that's what I got from this every
time I thought it was gonna go direction
I wasn't gonna like or I was gonna roll
my eyes and say oh with this shtick like
they added something new to it or they
really made it feel like you were
hearing this cliche for the first time
and I
I really really love that so yeah I I
don't have many complaints with this
movie I thought was really solid like I
said uh maybe the middle dragged a
little bit that that's about the most I
can get out of it because a guy I don't
really care that much about a talent can
tear a song out there but yeah I really
really enjoyed this I thought was very
very good I think you should go see it
here's some great music see some great
animation some good jokes just
everything's solid it's a solid movie
you should definitely go check it out
III don't think you're gonna draw that
made comparisons to book of life those
have seen it cuz I really like book of
life and I loved the way it looked and
everything but I I did not draw the
connection at all and I was ready to the
trailer almost right to dislike it too
after I saw the trailer after hearing
the oh the songs and that they don't
want songs he has to go find someone
that ran away bla bla bla but it it
really worked
it's like lilo and Stitch like how
that's kind of a knockoff VT but it
turns it into its own thing
and and I think you get something that's
really nice really creative and really
we're seeing on the big screen
so definitely go check it out tell me
what you think in the comments below I
really enjoyed it I'm curious if you
enjoyed it too
so that's about it and I will see you
next time take care
you